[Music]
hey baby we going to be here all day we
going to be here all day baby I like
this kind of party welcome back to the
way back everybody I am Ryan sichler
ryanr Ryan sichler on all your social
media come catch me on tour we're out
there doing it y'all everybody's uh
tickets in all your cities are available
on Ryan sickler very excited to have
this guest here ladies and gentlemen on
the way back Mark Norman everybody thank
you
what's shaking fatty good to be here
Sicky thank you for being here Mark
Norman on the way back sitting in that
seat looking back before uh before we
talk about you're growing up the plug
whatever you'd like please hey watch my
special on Netflix Soup To Nuts it's on
right now and then uh markn Norman
comedy.com for dates for tickets for
queefs and uh yeah Tuesdays are stories
we might be drunk podcast give it a whir
go gay live your life folks praise
Allah um all right so I know you grew up
way different than everybody else you
grew up in what you say is a dilapitated
mansion yep is that right you got it
also raised by uh trans nanny transvesti
so transvest of the curve are we allowed
to say that I think it's changed but she
was a drag queen she was a drag queen he
was a drag queen yeah it's just such a
wild thing you got a mansion but it's
not a great shape in great shape no it's
all banged up what's it like growing up
like that not good it messed me up I'm
all skittish and weird we got broken
into we were the white family so
everybody assumed we're in a mansion we
have a bazillion dollars but we had we
had nothing like robbers were
disappointed what is what does it look
like on the outside does it look like it
wouldn't have much or is it nice on the
outside when you get in it's not it's
not great on the outside but but
passible like I had a paint job but you
know there's uh cracks and and moldy
[__] and uh the the gu the yard was
overgrown so you're like wow the house
is huge but it was it was a little
haunted Housey and were you how old were
you when you first moved in it it was I
think 1988 so I was probably like five
or six when we moved in and then uh we
were there till I was about 145 oh damn
you're there for a long time oh too long
too long I walked in on a few
robberies wait you walked into your home
while it was being R oh yeah that was
pretty normal I I we used to have an
alarm that would go woo woo woo woo and
it would wake up at 2: in the morning
and you're like a 9-year-old just kind
of oh there's a guy downstairs how about
that you know Dad's in the boxers with
the baseball bat and you're like my dad
might die how about this what if they
shoot him you know it's just it's a
wacky way to grow up as a kid hell yeah
dude so big bummer and you that violated
feel security yes I mean I've had my car
broken into and and stolen that's not my
home obviously but still I I know what
you mean about that's what I felt I was
like these mother strangers
[__] violating my [__] I
remember I got robbed in New York this
guy came up the fire escape opened my
bedroom window and he get the [__] out
of here yeah and he walked o I saw his
footprints on my bed cuz the window is
right by the bed and he and just the
footprints was like God you this
[__] was here walking on my bed
it it bums you out so you guys don't
have a lot of money growing up I was
asking you this before we record like
were you a vacation family were you a
did you cuz I I also was talking to a
friend about this like we never flew I
think we did Disneyland World excuse me
once we never flew anywhere no if we
went somewhere we drove same the car and
it didn't matter how many hours it was
we were hauling ass 100% we you know I I
Liv in grew up in Louisiana so Florida
was Souther so we'd always we drove to
Florida once or twice you know hit the
beach I drove to San Antonio with my
folks once but that was about it you
know I was mentioning before you you go
to your friend's house the mantle is all
these photos of ski trips and Grand
Canyon and you know know Big Bear you
know all that [__] I'm like wow what is
that like I didn't see snow till I was
you know
38 I would see those pictures too I'm
like man you guys look like you do cool
stuff what do you so you organized the
whole ski trip yeah like no I've never
done anything like that insane and you
see Mickey you know there the mom and
dad with Mickey you know and they got
the mouse ears going I was like holy
moly this fames got it together so what
were Summers like for you guys then were
you just out and about in the neighbor
neighborhoods very feral I was a skate
kid skateboarding so I would just you
know skateboard from like 9:00 a.m. to
9: at night that was was your first
board I had a girl Eric Cen mhm and I
had a chocolate I had a I liked girl I
don't know why I didn't want to seem gay
you know so I got the girl boards but
yeah I just all we do was SK it's free
and you just go get go grind on Ledges
and you get kicked out we got chased a
lot because skating was very white back
when I was doing it and now it's kind of
Multicultural but like you know you'd be
on a basketball court you just wanted
smooth cement and then you get chased
out of there they throw your boards over
the fence and [__] it was it was a
little rough this place here La
specifically Southern California I
should say I've I legitimately see
people using skateboards for a absolute
legitimate mode of transportation oh
yeah more here than any I'm I see the
guy all the time with the long board
with the 12pack I'm like this
motherfucker's got a level of confidence
in him that I wish I had can't do the
long board there's something about a
board going from here to here that I
just don't I can't accept that life he's
in bare feet he's got glass up on his
should like on the sidewalks and [__]
I'm like how you [__] doing this
that's all Venice [__] I'm jealous with
that guy and I hate that guy at the same
time were you a street skater ramps both
we were Street skating all day and then
we built a halfpipe in my backyard which
was we built it from stolen construction
equipment so it took like 4 years to
build because you had to like needed a
piece of plywood we couldn't find it you
couldn't afford it he go to Home Depot
that shit's like $200 so yeah we built a
halfpipe in the backyard we do that all
day hose water Good Times hose water I
love it that's what the Orioles are
doing that's their whole thing the Homer
hose when they hit a home run they come
home come to The Dugout and they do a
bong hit out of the hose is that right
oh that's a nice little throwback good
for the Orioles hell yeah they're
they're killing it now they're good
finally goddamn Yeah Boy Baltimore you
got a Babe Ruth I believe is from there
originally yes Edgar Allen Poe that's
why the Ravens are the Ravens because of
Edgar Allen Po and the Raven how'd I
miss that yeah right there their mascots
are Edgar Allen and Poe they have three
Ravens they kind of like cut two of them
out of the Edgar and Allen got fired I
think and they just use po now whoa Po
got hurt he got injured last year and he
was in a wheelchair so he brought Edgar
and house ah never more I know way too
much about these masks who else give me
some more alumni I love alumni what you
talking about Baltimore yeah oh Barry
levenson oh [__] does he did he do Diner
yeah Diner was bore yep um and and his
uh to get married she had to know the
Colts fight song cuz it used to be the
Baltimore Colts right right um You have
John Waters of course oh yeah crybaby
there's so many cele what's that little
neighborhood my buddy lives list I want
to give this shout out Antonio Freeman
Antonio Freeman I'm going to tell you
why that I was saying he's a football
player that um if you do you a football
fan yeah I like the Saints there was a
crazy catch years ago Brett Favre
through to Antonio freem was like a
Monday night and it like landed on his
ass you ever see that just literally and
as his body rolls over the ball
miraculously stays with him and he keeps
it and it's a it's an insane [__]
catch wow so I'm hanging out with this
dude who's friends with Antonio Freeman
he's like you got to listen to this
comic he's one of my favorite comics and
we happen to be talking about Baltimore
celebrities um I think it was with Ari
actually and uh I don't men mention him
and he was like man this guy didn't
mention me [__] this guy you better get
it out so Antonio Freeman there you go
dude there you go Antonio and I've also
had balls laying on my ass Tupac t wait
Tupac Tupac spent a lot of time in
Baltimore oh give me a get out of
here uh he went to Baltimore School of
Arts uh Joan Jet Joan Jet's a Baltimore
girl Oro fan still an Oreo fan hell yeah
uh David burn from the Talking Heads is
from lands down outside of uh that's a
trash Town that's oh yeah my grandmother
live right next to it it's trash
Timonium is no picnic either no that's
where I went to college out there at
talson yeah yeah um yeah there's a lot
of uh Baltimore celebs I mean obviously
the sports stars Ripken and sure Ed
Norton the ACT is from Maryland Josh
Charles is from Maryland there's a lot
of a lot of them all right you know
obviously you got the wire you got the
wire and the new one but it's a cop show
yeah it was U we own the city there it
is burn whatever name is he was great
how do you like the accent is he nailing
it he Nails it all right I I'll tell you
for a guy who doesn't have that accent
he [__] Nails it hell yeah he Nails
it all right unlike every New Orleans
show I guarantee down about to buy you
I'm like shut the [__] up nobody talks
like that we got Ellen we got uh yeah
not not much from Aon Neville uh what's
that guy's name the black guy he's a
hell of a
musician for Mar
him he's a trumpet but there a young guy
he's super cool he was on John Baptist
oh John Baptist I thought you were going
to say Harry
conic he's a hunk he was an independence
day yeah yeah we got we got a couple we
got a couple Punky Johnson I believe you
know her yeah yeah I think she's New
Orleans New Orleans as well Theo is
about 30 minutes out yeah so yeah we got
a couple Ellen won't claim us come on
Ellen really what does she where does
she say she's from she just doesn't
mention it I'm like you're from uh Nola
baby The Big Easy yeah that's why you
got cancelled you big Les
big throw us a bone will you uh What
About Pets growing up you have any pets
growing up we were a big cat family uh
because cats need no attention they're
low maintenance they lived outside uh
they I hear them at the night time you
know getting raped by other cats and
[__] up the ass uh but you come out
the next morning they're hanging they're
there they got a little blood on it and
but they're eating that shitty food uh
we had a dog once named Shadow it was
like a black dog like out of uh Wizard
of Oz whatever you call those like Toto
Toto thing yeah exactly and uh it got
eaten by ants what it got [__] up and
went into an ant pile and the Ants just
swarmed and they killed him that was a
rough thing to see as a seven-year-old
yeah came out and saw that just saw the
dead dog with the ants just crawl oh the
image it was too dark damn dude brutal
brutal it was a tough Town tell me like
I mean it's a big old house with people
running in and out are you terrified at
night sleeping did you sleep in your own
room did you have a brother siblings
that you shared a room with or anything
I know it's a mansion so you wouldn't
need to but did you oh yeah older
brother I'd creep into his room I did a
lot of uh a lot of sleeping between the
parents I was a bed weter as well how
old till how old oh jeez I mean it was
off and on I hit 13 14 really yeah I
think the trauma it kicks something up
and uh I used to pee on a lot of one
night stands in college cuz you know
you're so [__] housed and then you had
to do that thing where you woke up urine
everywhere and you're like what' you do
oh gez you know CU it's a pool so I
could blame it on her a lot uh I did a
lot of buying flowers a lot of a lot of
dry cleaning i' pay for girls sheets a
lot of flipping mattresses I did that
one time I was uh staying with the girl
dating and she was house sitting for a
family and we got wasted and when I woke
up I had pissed that family's like just
pissed it I might as well just stood up
and peed on it like it was soaked it was
soaked it's a horrible feeling she like
would you do and I couldn't I mean it
was all under me and I was like I just I
pissed all over these people not a turn
on the ladies don't love that no they're
not big fans yeah you find the right one
she might be there you go tell me um I
also have this apparatus that a doctor
gave me this is how old I am this what I
want to talk about how you stop well I
tried some some salt pills also my dad
was he's old school so he's like no
liquids after six okay which is harder
than you think both of my brothers were
bedw so they were too old and I'm I you
just did something with your hand that
I'm oh curious if they it sounds like
they might have had the same thing yeah
well uh first of all no no liquids after
six was tough cuz you eaten a bag of
Doritos at 8:00 p.m. and you're
likeo your mouth is like a Sahara it's
like my wife's vagina it's bone dry and
so a doctor said you know I said my wits
end here I tried everything tried pills
and all this [__] nothing worked
I wasn't going to put those [__]
Huggies on I I couldn't I had too much
Integrity I was like I can't wear a
diaper so my doctor gave me this thing
where it Clips onto your shirt and it
goes wire goes down to a sensor that
detects moisture there it is yeah there
it is oh my God this is bringing me back
we just talked about this with somebody
else way my brothers had the same thing
it was white it was much mine was white
earlier than this yeah this is looks a
little too high
and it was a you had to wear an
undershirt where you like you said it
was a little patch up here a buzzer it
was a buzzer up here be yeah and then it
was a cord and then they would you had
to sew the little like the pad in so
when you pissed it it would Buzz yes and
it was
on and I was like oh but it worked it
worked for them oh that work for you I
pissed on it so much I shorted it out I
broke it so it didn't work for me and I
threw that thing in the garbage yeah
whizzed all over it it's still an
electronic at the end of the day but I
can pee man I got like gallons of piss
any Edward 40 hands you ever play that
uhuh what's that what you never played
that uh-uh that's where you get two 40s
in one in each hand and you tape them
you duct tape them to your hand I've
never heard this yeah let's hear some
old drinking games so you duct tape into
your hands and whoever pees first loses
so you got to drink a both cuz you so it
forces you to drink there it is I
thought everybody did this I've never
heard of this ever oh yeah and uh so you
just sit there and you just sit there
and you keep drinking and the first one
that pisses themselves loses I'd win
every time it's the only athletic thing
I was good at 80 o and I just got a
bladder the size of lizo I can just I
can hold it in and uh I would win every
time because you know you got to chug it
CU everybody's got to pee and you want
to rip your hands off and so you can you
can hold your dick or whatever but I
could go I could do it all day long what
other drinking games did you guys play
well we did the beer PA we did um a lot
of lot of what was the quarters you
bounce always good there was a couple
card games called drug dealer did you
ever play this one no it's like you get
a group of people together and you know
obviously you're getting shitfaced but
one uh person has the ace they're the
drug dealer one person has the king
they're the cop everyone else just has a
regular C oh okay and you're supposed to
sit there and drink and you're supposed
to close your eyes so if I say Mark I
think Mark's a drug dealer and you flip
your card over and you've got an eight
I'm taking eight drinks oh [__] all
right I think Kirsten's the drug dealer
no and you got to go until you figure
out who it is M but the thing is as
people are opening their eyes slowly cuz
everyone's going to the drug dealer
needs to wink at somebody he needs to
make a deal got it sometimes you wink at
the cop though and you're busted
immediately and so it's a bunch of you
know drunks trying to figure out but
also you don't know you know like he
just wink you know what I mean bad Winks
when you're drinking we played another
drion game called uh drigg and
driving that was a big one and just try
not to die that was the whole game uh
boy I remember one time I got drunk in
high school I had I had the old cutless
and I woke up on the highway like the
freeway what and I woke up and my two
left front and back tires were over the
rail so I was like like coming for
traffic the other way no no no like the
you know there's a guard rail is about
you know yay high on the side of the
freeway and and I'm up it was like a
skateboard move I the rail was between
the car and I'm up like that and the car
is up you know and I'm like ah I woke up
and I jerked it and got off of the the
rail and uh my two tires were flat I was
riding on the rim and I parked the car
in like an Alleyway and I called my
friend and we had to go from junkyard to
junkyard cuz I lived at home so I
couldn't have two flat tires you know I
couldn't get home on the on the rim so I
had to call my friend and we wanted to
hide it and we went junkyard to junkyard
looking for a
1971 two left side cutless rims good
luck we went to junkyard after junkyard
we finally found one two of them we put
them on the car you know [__] seven
hours has passed eight hours I parked at
my house we didn't realize it one's blue
one's red so my dad comes he's like
what's up with your your rims I was like
it's a new it's cool you know the kids
are all doing the colored rooms and he
was like oh all right whatever and we
got away with
it kirs you have any questions you want
to ask Mark I do uh being from New
Orleans you got any good ghost stories
any spooky stuff happened as a kid uh no
real ghost stuff uh we got real
break-ins you know I wish I had a
[__] ghost a ghost stands there it's
a little girl in a night gown it goes
with a doll you know this was a a guy
named Tyrone with a with a [__] 2x4
and a crowbar so I would kill for a
ghost you know some woo that's nothing I
can I can sleep through that you know
but the one time I walked in and there
was a guy just kind of like big dude
just kind of looking around and I was so
young and naive I go hey excuse me sir I
just walked into the living room I was
home alone and I go oh can I help you
and he goes H I'm looking for your dad
and I go oh let me go look and I'm
walking around the house huge house I'm
going Dad Dad I get upstairs dad I look
out the back window he's running through
the backyard with a computer monitor
under his arm I was like
[__] so oh no yeah that was and
then you you know your parents come home
where's the computer oh uh this guy took
it and they're like what and I had to
tell and then they're like Jesus Christ
my son was talking to this criminal
robber guy so they're like oh I had to
call the police I had to describe the
guy it was it was wild did you guys ever
in your drinking nights ever go like
walk through cemeteries or anything like
that you ever do any old houses or cuz
we used to go in old hospitals that were
now closed stuff we would do that yeah
yeah all that abandoned [__]
[__] we went to one it was a lot of gang
writings on the wall and there was dead
cats like skinned cats so probably some
Satan [__] in there who knows but I
remember we were like all right we got
to get the [__] out of here it was who
knows when these guys will show up
there's dead cats let's get the hell out
of here we used to go to this Hospital a
tuberculosis hospital then once
tuberculosis was cured it looks like
someone came in and was like they cured
it and everybody just got up and walked
out that second like it there's we would
go through the hallways and it would
always be some you know pentagram down
here on and you'd shine a flashlight
there' be a wheelchair and you just look
[__] scary as [__] a wheelchair and
just you know graffiti all over the
walls you'd go into the morg and they
would still have toe tags in there
people grabbed toe tags out of there
holy moly and uh they did have a cult at
this one house we were in it and as they
pulled up we're craw there's like four
of us crawling out to get out away from
them cuz we were scared to [__] death
but we used to love that [__] we if it
was an old abandoned house in a field we
park and go walk and go through it and
stuff oh my never solo obviously never
solo you guys never did that ah that
wasn't our bag it was it was a lot of
parking lot drinking we do GHB you ever
do that no I've never done oh you never
did GP you fill up like a Gatorade cap
just with a little bit of liquid and you
shoot it it was like having uh you know
40 beers you know so uh yeah it was a
dark days out there you know just
vandalizing nothing to do just dumb kids
just with the city that is your oyster
and we're drinking and driving and and
vandalizing and breaking things we used
to drive around and knock side view
mirrors off cars oh you did yeah we did
the mailbox baseball when standby me
came out we saw that and uh had a friend
of mine he was he was doing so much of
it that uh one time he's like come with
me I'm like I don't want to go he's like
come with me and as few of us go and he
hits this one guy's mailbox and this is
that one guy that one guy you don't [__]
with he got in his car and he chased us
and he got the tag reported it to the
police they came and scared our friend
and said look this is a federal offense
uh they put him on like some kind of
Probation and [__] and told him if it
happens again they're going to arrest
him but we were [__] these mailboxes
it felt good to get those aluminum was
just full you see a nice mailbox
somebody really put time you know a dick
teenager and it's aluminum it's got the
wood slats to go around a little rooster
on it you're like oh this
Ro Fu this one up right here yeah that's
that's a good time boy not a care in the
world but now we're on the other end of
it now if some kid in my mailbox Furious
like that's all I got I hate my wife I'm
sober now my mail that's all I got and
plus sometimes you hit it in the mail
would go everywhere that was a nice
feeling to we used to uh there was this
kid we used to [__] his mailbox up so
much they finally got tired of it and
they just mail they nailed a 5 gallon
bucket into a a
2x4 and then we cuz we would put m80s in
it and it would blow the back out of it
and the sides off of that [__]
damn M did you guys go tubin yeah we
would go tubin winter tubing not winter
tubing winter tubing Jeffrey tubing
wait wait what how the hell do you tube
in the winter it must be Baltimore is
freezing well we got Maryland so we'd
have tons of snow we'd hit up the hills
we' get big 18 wheeler in tubes where
you could put two or three people on
them and then you're just hauling ass
down these Hills on tubes and jumping
and [__] you know that kind that's good
being like uh floating in the river and
stuff like we would do that a little bit
in the summer but we more winter tube
that is just asking for a problem like
we had one kid he dove in drunk out of
his mind dove in broke his neck shallow
that's the story got pulled out on a
stretcher you know the whole thing no he
after about 6 months I mean he had to do
the physical therapy the whole thing
with the the the double bars whatever
you know the parallel bars he came back
around clay good to have you Budd bud
and then one time I went with my high
school girlfriend and a bunch of jerk
off buddies and we did tubed all day you
just drink on the ACH ofalia that was
the river he's just drinking drinking
drinking sun goes down we get back in
her car she had a little Honda Civic and
we're driving through the woods to get
back to New Orleans and my buddy in the
back goes gun it gun it so she's uh you
know 16-year-old girl she you Gunn it
and she gunned it and then the road
ended it was a pebble Road and she
jerked the wheel and we flipped into a
ditch we landed upside down I under the
seat belt I dropped you know and she's
crying we're all fine the glass is
broken the car is ruined tough to get
the couldn't get the door open had to go
you know go out the window upside down
the bottom of the cars at the top and
the whole thing was crazy the cops came
uh she was drunk and crying and she was
cute cute 16-year-old you know and her
boob popped out and so she's crying
giving a report to the police officer
and she's got a big old 16-year-old jug
just hanging out of a swimsuit and
they're all like oh it's a bunch of fat
you know loser cops yeah and they're
like oh yeah okay sounds good and uh
yeah big big boob out there and uh I
think it helped like like the tow truck
drive we got in the car she got uh like
a a warning and then had the car got
total they got towed out of there you
know and she got a new car yeah those
were those were good times curs than any
more questions um as a kid any weird uh
any weird irrational fears or like weird
nightmares you'd ever have uh well I
mean I was I had real fears again I had
the the break-ins but uh I was scared of
uh uh homeless people do you have that I
don't know if that's irrational but like
I'd see a I'd picture homeless people in
my house you know coming after me I was
always worried about a guy in the house
that was like a big I still get
triggered I live in New York I have a
tiny shitbox apartment and I'm like
there's a guy under the bed I know it
there's a guy under the bed right now I
hear those noises too how about the
shower curtain you know that like
there's a guy behind there just thank
God I have all that still it's like
beaten into me it's in my wiring the
cement is dry what about you you got any
fears I was really U my daughter almost
got hit by a car and it unhinged me and
I was Jesus Christ I became scared to
fly and scared of heights and then I
went to do I went to EMDR therapy and it
cured me of both so la it cured me of
both I needed it I'm thank God I asked
Dr Drew I'm like Dr Drew we were doing
an episode together and he said some
similar thing had happened to him he's
like go try this therapy it's not just
talk therapy it's it really has um a
Finish Line hell yeah and it did I sleep
on my flights now I live on the top of
my building now yeah it worked like a
[__] that's great yeah oh what
about uh dogs scared the [__] out of
like you know when you walk by a fence
it's like sing his face through the the
bars that [__] me up as a kid I also
had a a recurring dream for years about
lions eating my family you ever have
that no I had this weird dream where
we'd be on Safari me my brother my mom
my dad my grandmother and we would be
walking and then Lions would like three
Lions would chase us and we'd run off a
cliff somebody give that a goo that must
mean something yeah and you had it a lot
huh had it a lot all the time I was like
oh there's that lion dream again it was
you know I'd have it like 10 times a
year I've never talked about that
publicly wow I just I forgot about that
well Mark Norman I know we got to get
you out of here thank you so much for
sitting here with us on the way back one
more time plug promote everything you'd
like heyy Soup To Nuts on Netflix
Markman comedy.com for tickets check out
Tuesdays of stories we might be drunk
queef it up we'll see you in hell
comedy as always ryan.com come out see
me on tour all tickets available at
ryan.com
[Music]
com